hello I would like to invite all of you  personally to the upcoming stoicon  conference which is international online  the biggest Gathering of stoics  worldwide and this is our 10th year  going so if you have any interest in  stoic philosophy and practice you will  not want to miss this event we've got  some great panels and talks and  workshops lined up to help you learn all  about stoicism and how to apply it  within your daily life to improve your  level of Happiness resilience and all  those other good things look at the link  below you can get yourself a ticket  there and you can do so by making a  donation at any level we want to make  this as accessible to people worldwide  as possible so I hope that I will see  you there